[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream 115 q a segment
we are going to get right to it as zack
has urgent rocketry business
where they will no doubt be uh using mal
information to the fullest extent
possible in the furtherance of rocketry
indeed
okay our question from the discord this
week
is during your conversation with jordan
peterson there is some discussion about
what the female version of the hero's
journey would be
heather was about to answer when she was
interrupted with mr peterson's answer an
example beauty and the beast
unfortunately the conversation didn't
circle back after that i'm curious to
hear heather's perspective on the female
heroes journey
i would love to spend some time on this
i'm not sure my head is in the right
space right now um
so i i think i want to say just a little
bit here and then promise to come back
to this maybe in part of our main
podcast at some point
um
i will say that uh when when jordan when
dr peterson
said beauty and the beast i think i was
off camera and i think i went
something like that like really um and i
hadn't watched it and did we watch it or
did i just so i watched it maybe with
toby i i watched it um after that
and i was expecting to be um
disturbed by it uh and and i wasn't it
was actually a a much more compelling
story than uh than
than i thought than the
um
then i thought that i had in my head
um that said it's still um
it is still
different from and lesser than
uh the hero's journey as told in
traditionally male terms
because while the heroes journey told in
traditionally male terms um often ends
in partnership the journey itself is
singular and independent and um and
finding yourself such that in part you
can be your best self so that you can
then be in partnership with someone
and um while there was you know some of
that um in the in the framing of
whatever the beauty character's name is
um in beauty and the beast um it still
feels largely in service of partnership
and i think that is you know that sort
of is the is the most
noble version of the of the disconnect
between how
here a hero's journey in our heroine's
journey has been traditionally
understood that um
the men are both singular under
themselves independent beings who may
then also form in partnership and the
women are primarily defined by
partnership
and that feels um you know just that
feels that feels wrong
and obviously there's historical reason
for it um but
you know we deserve and many women live
something in which you know in any in
any awesome partnership there are there
are three entities
right and um you know there are the two
individuals and and and the partnership
itself
and
it would be lesser if
the individual one of the individuals
was primarily there as part of the
partnership as opposed to also also
their own being so um i want us i want
to think more on what i mean i think
part of part of what i probably would
have said there and i loved that
conversation that we had with jordan it
was fabulous
um
and i encourage people to go to it if
they haven't listened to it
um
but i think part of what i would have
said was
uh
i i think it may be less uh less
singular and less like there may be less
opportunity for there to be a sort of
chembellian
heroes journey uh that can then be found
in you know tolkien and and star wars
and you know all these other places
precisely because um
frankly of the different constraints
that women are under both anatomically
and physiologically and therefore
downstream of that to some degree
historically anyway socially and
economically such that there will be
different ways to uh to discover um
discover the hero within for women um
and that's you know that's a hedge
that's not an answer but it's it's
approaching one and a promise for more
thinking about it later no i think it's
i think it's right on target and you
know at some level men and women can do
whatever they want
and so there's one way in which the new
hero's journey
there's a possibility to write that
hero's journey with either a male or
female
protagonist to the extent that we're
doing something new but to the extent
that it feels like well there ought to
be
female heroes journeys part of this is
built into the asymmetry and not just of
the constraints that women face but also
the asymmetry of
sexual reproduction right right that's
the anatomical and physical
physiological limitations but that's not
it's this the stuff that is the
behavioral consequence of that that i'm
pointing to if you think about hero's
journeys
typically
these are
pre
uh pre-relationship right adventures
that these male heroes now not
everything
odysseus is obviously
coming back for penelope yeah but
but the basic point is
men because women are the limiting sex
men
earn
the attention of women and so there's a
natural extension of that that becomes a
hero's journey and that's one of the
driving features of many of them whether
or not it's defined that way
and that's that's something
for which there is not going to be a
symmetry
right and the point is it's not really
i i think all of these stories are going
to need updates because
there are modern circumstances just
simply aren't a good analog for those
circumstances for which those stories
were written and as we've said
you can't
you can't write a myth you can write a
narrative selection turns it into a myth
over time if it's resonant enough
um but you also you want to be really
careful there's this kind of naivete
that we have
where it's like we can look at the
asymmetry in hero's journey stories and
you know there's definitely a sexual
asymmetry
and imagine that that's something in
need of correction and the answer is
maybe not right and you know there's no
i don't think i i don't think that we
can just
put men and women equally into into the
stories that that exist
would work in some cases and under some
conditions but it won't work universally
it's i mean and that that is the mistake
of a naive kind of feminism that
predates even the like toxic kind of
feminism that is pervading
much feminist thinking now the naive
feminism being
we're the same not the same stop we're
not the same and therefore expecting
um
identity as opposed to equality under
the law
um is is a fool's errand yeah i was just
going to mention i was trying to think
of what stories resonate for me that
don't strike me as falsely portraying
women but do have that heroic
characteristic and i was thinking back
to
contact
uh carl sagan
yeah i'm just trying to think of
i know it's carl sagan but i'm gonna
have to jody foster in the movie um you
know essentially is the hero scientist
um who
figures out what's going on and you know
results in our contact with this
uh
advanced alien race but
um
yeah there's nothing
there's nothing sext in any of that
right inherently well i mean you know
she's a very female character right it's
not a nudity but there's nothing about
her discovery there's nothing about the
journey um you know the narrative has
has her as a woman but it could have
equally been done and it would have
looked a little bit different if that
character had been male yep and there
will be cases
um presumably it will be harder to find
the cases where a male character
could have have been drawn as female
because those will be more likely to you
know be from a little longer back
in which all the expectations of
not just the responsibilities but
largely the social perks that come along
with being male will be just sort of
baked into the story and so you couldn't
it would just be silly it would be
absurd to say like oh it could be a
woman's like
not given that he acted with the you
know like
with the understanding that there was
you know going to be a dinner waiting
back home for him
whenever it was right um but you know
like
darwin couldn't have been a woman right
like in
in could now if you decided that he
could now but yeah obviously it's a
no no no that's not what i meant
no
no um
no young woman of means
was going off to be
the you know
talk only companion of a
a boat captain right around the world
like
just
maybe for all sorts of reasons like
you're gonna be the one woman on a boat
full of men who haven't seen anyone like
right it's just it just doesn't work
right and that's the damn shame like
there were pro and in fact gosh who was
it there was a novel written
there was a novel written
about um
a
woman in
like a botanist woman in the uk
who would have imagined uh was sort of
co-discovering along with darwin and
wallace uh the natural selection
and um she does some exploring but of
course can't do much i can't it's i'll
look it up or someone will will figure
it out and tell us um quite quite
beautifully done and in a compelling way
where it doesn't pretend that darwin
could have been female or that wallace
could have been female because neither
of them given the lives they actually
lived in that era could have done it as
a woman
they could have done it as a woman if
they were married to a man maybe and
we're going someplace and then it could
always be like no don't like it
you do stay away because i've got this
fear of protection
um even if he's not right here but the
fact is that that was necessary until
very recently and that of course is one
of the
amazing features of modernity that women
really can go so many places uh and and
be at far lower risk than we ever have
been in the past from being assaulted
um i would just add
finally i thought there were some
very good there were some missteps of
course and some will say that the entire
last season was a misstep but game of
thrones
actually you and i don't think that i
don't i don't think that i think it was
good although i well we'll come back to
it some other time maybe but um
but
there were some
very good
heroic female characters in that uh
arya stark
um brianne of tarth
um even arguably
um
sansa stark in the end who does not
start out heroic at all
done but there was also some stuff that
was really well done and i think it does
provide a kind of blueprint you know it
is um
you know it is
sort of like a modern um
[Music]
fellowship of the ring kind of
phenomenon yeah absolutely uh so just to
just to wrap this up i
figured out it was actually it's
elizabeth gilbert who's most famous for
writing eat pray love which i've never
read
and i know takes a lot of crap for i
don't even know what because i haven't
read it um
but she wrote i think after that after
she became you know very famous for for
writing that and for being portrayed by
some famous actress who i can't remember
in the movie version um
the signature of all things
uh is this novel um
a fictionalization of uh the discovery
of natural selection by darwin wallace
and this imaginary female botanist in
the uk and it's really it's it's
terrific uh for those of you who are
interested in i don't know what such
things would be here but such things
all right let us go to the first
question from
darkhorsemissions.com this week
we have oh it looks like it logged me
out um so i will just ask one question
i'm gonna have to log back in while you
start um
wow what is going on sorry i don't know
if you know i i should
i'm sorry i got i have to log back in
here
okay oh that yeah
apologies
gotta set everything up again
okay
how do you manage your stress and anger
through all of this i've recently
started being more vocal about what i
see and think because i've been
ie i've been to ottawa to see it for
myself
it's been hard to keep my cool when
discussing these issues with people who
are getting a completely different set
of information and then anger and
anxiety stay with me for days
any advice i'm sure will help
you're the best
oh man it's hard
it's hard
yeah uh i mean i would say i think
you're focused on the right question
yeah because
the uh
the anger plays a role um
but
to the extent that it shows up
uh
just sort of arbitrarily
it's
probably doing more harm than good um
so you know controlling it so it becomes
a
positive driving force rather than an
arbitrary disrupter is
is important
i don't know about
how i mean i guess the only tool i would
say is
it seems to me that if you think about
is this
particular anger
serving the purpose that i believe needs
serving
anytime the answer is no
then your system should tamp it down
but i think um
it can feel though
i think i think the anger is sort of
vaguely covering a sense i often feel
um
of you know maybe this is the wrong it's
got like the wrong valence to it but
like of impotence like oh my god
the person i'm talking to is so
blind to
what is happening as i see it that even
as i try to say the things that i've
seen without
analysis without interpretation
the blindness continues and i and it
becomes
anger because i just feel like is there
is there nothing
i can say is there nothing that i can
bring
to this and i think that is part of why
just constitutionally where i am but
also part of why i keep returning to
like yeah but the people
who are
accepting vac sports because it allows
them to eat where they want to eat
how
how can we bring to them some salient
truths
that reveals
that at the very least they need to
recognize that they are benefiting from
the beginning of a two-tiered society
and also i just want to say that the
snoring you're hearing the background is
matty on the floor behind brett yeah i'm
not even asleep
well
one thing i would say is focus on
tight
circles that are clear rather than
trying to reveal the whole picture right
you may with regard to information or
people
both when you
attempt to reach someone
trying to present the picture like oh
you are seeing an entirely different
world you need to see the world i'm in
in order to even understand what's going
on you're not going to be able to convey
that world right and you look crazy
you're going to sound like a crazy
person
but if you say look
let's find something over which we
should be able to reach agreement right
you're so good at this is there
a justification for vaccinating children
against code right let's put aside
whether you and i should be vaccinated
let's talk about children let's just
talk about the simple facts right
you're right and then you can talk about
the fact that
a children don't suffer healthy children
no suffer from severe
covid it's a very rare thing
that there are
significant adverse events and that we
don't know how to calibrate them because
nobody's doing a diligent job of
tracking these things
and so the question is you're you've got
a risk some of that risk we can't
calibrate we don't know what happens if
you're vaccinated at nine years old we
don't know what happens when you're 20
and 30 and 50.
um
but what we do know is already reason to
be alarmed and there's no reason to
vaccinate a healthy child of that age
especially a male child right can we
just agree
that somehow that system
is recommending this even though a
logical person would at least have
substantial questions about why you
would do this i think your answer here
has exactly
um exactly the approach that that can
allay the anxiety and the like the
impotence like oh i have i have to share
so many things in order for you to see
through my eyes no right like you're not
someone who is really two people who are
really seeing totally different sides
of this public health science media
educational landscape and it's all of
those things and it's more
are not
going to be able to exactly move into
you know it's it's not going to the
anamorphic arc arc um art trek is not
going to be possible just stand where
i'm standing here for a moment because
you can't stand the other person
standing for a moment you have to have
seen
so many things for so many you know
frankly at least weeks if not months
but so pick something pick a piece take
a piece of it and you know maybe it's
you know maybe it's that
maybe it's
uh the truckers convoy is a bunch of
nazis and uh
white supremacists and just show them
some of the live stream or show them the
portraits from daniel ponte or
you know show them show them some
pieces
and
and ask and ask for the counter
the counter evidence because all of the
stuff on the other side of that is is
claims
and sometimes it's people claiming oh
you know
the best i've seen is my sister lives
there and she says that it's been really
hard
and you know when those things are
chased through or followed through
it as far as i've seen it always ends in
like well the honking was hard to live
with
before it stopped like the honking yeah
i'm sure it was
and tyranny is harder
it's harder to live with yeah
uh honking is as bad as it is and i
actually thought it was kind of a
mistake um
uh is a
rather measured response to tyranny
which is what we are looking at but you
know there are a dozen you want to show
these zach you want to show um so the
person who sends me the discord question
every week sent me
included this with the question which i
just think is
that was great
yeah
i hope i assume that's a canada goose
i think it is it is
it is an albino canada goose maybe yeah
um anyway
uh you know in front of what
has some relationship to the japanese fl
anyway it's a very international
uh movement well it's it's also again
sort of um
soviet art-ish yeah yeah
um but there are lots of places that you
can
take somebody just to see a piece right
like yeah how long have we not been
recommending vitamin d right suddenly as
of last week that's tougher well okay
now that's easier because the absence of
public health people be like well i'm
sure they've been doing it you just
haven't seen it it's like no they have
not
so now this week we all agree vitamin d
is important i don't know why we're not
recommending it but we all agree but
yeah some of us knew that many many
months ago
why is this not a feature of our
discussion or the um
absolute uh insanity surrounding natural
immunity yeah right so these these two
are harder i think
um they are they're they're going to be
less compelling to people because they
will say well i i don't know i'm sure
i'm sure that's been said right whereas
going after
a an active
media campaign and saying this thing
that they are saying we should do or
this thing they are saying is true is
patently false
how do you reconcile those two things
whereas saying look there's been no
recommendation of vitamin d it is you
know as you've said many times as i've
said
as i actually heard honorable brian
peckford say in his conversation with
jordan peterson
the low-hanging fruit yep um but you can
say that to someone who's standing in a
totally different place in all of this
and they can be like
well i haven't heard it but i'm sure i'm
sure they're saying it i mean obviously
they'd be saying it right that could be
the response that comes back that's not
then for me anyway in those
conversations i get i get hung up like i
just don't know what to say to you like
it's not being said but i can't prove an
absence i mean you can
the fact is
if vitamin d were a minor contributor
to
uh
protection from kovid then you could
make that argument but the degree of
protection is so substantial relative to
everything else being delivered that the
fact that
somebody has not had it offered to them
as a
as a potentially protective agent you
know do you know that you are likely to
be vitamin d deficient how do i know
that right i know that because where you
live you couldn't possibly be making
enough and diet is not a good substitute
unless you're supplementing right
why is nobody telling you that that is
playing a huge role in your
vulnerability right
the point is any system
that did mention it and didn't get that
information to you while we thought
about
experimental treatments that system is a
complete failure and the fact is it
didn't recommend it why didn't they
recommend it they knew we knew yeah
that's that's a compelling approach but
it takes more um
i think it takes more rhetorical skill
um than than the first two
perhaps next question
now that we know
now that we know that the scientific
consensus on covid was mainly
established by silence dissenting
opinions and dissenters keeping quite
out of fear
can we still trust the consensus on
climate change
so this is a question we've
addressed
a bit
a number of times we've never spent
you know we haven't spent hours talking
about it publicly but um
i don't know you want to summarize yeah
i would say you cannot trust the
consensus on climate change at all right
the consensus is going to be subject to
a bias in what is allowed to be
published and to the extent that we have
a complex phenomenon which is climate
change and there is a
authoritarian
instinct to silence those who would say
anything that would cause people not to
worry about climate change of course
that subject matter is going to be
garbaged up by that bias and there and
there's evidence that this has happened
with with scientists um you know climate
change dissenters how could it not how
could it not sure but that said right
there are
very
simple things that are dependent on a
consensus that you can assess right like
glacial retreat
like the
craters in the yama peninsula that have
done
novel things where you've had explosive
ejections of methane
what to make of those things
is not perfectly clear
but the idea that we do have a problem
that climate is changing that human
activity and the alteration of
atmospheric chemistry is likely a
contributor it's a very
old
hypothesis based on very simple
chemistry so
there ought to be a conversation what we
do with a consensus that is clearly um
born of uh coercion yeah i guess i would
also just say just sort of flag here
that one of the objections that you and
i have had is the conflation of uh
talking about climate change with
talking about the environment more
broadly
and um
just like there are empirical measures
by which you can assess
uh that uh the the climate is changing
such as the two that you just mentioned
there are many other things that are
are putting
all of the systems that we actually
depend on as humans even those of you
who live in cities and never see green
at risk and
habitat loss for instance you know
leaving
pretending that one acre or hectare of
forest is equivalent to any other
hectare or acre of forest as long as
it's just called forest
is is beyond foolish you know a boreal
forest in canada
and a
piece of
uh ecuador and amazon uh are do not
bring the same kinds of things and you
know i hate this phrase but like the
same ecosystem services
uh to either the area just around them
or or the planet they just don't they're
not a forest is not the same as forest
it's not a category that way
and so you know when you as we have not
for two years now but you know when you
when you travel deeply into and your job
is researching within for instance
tropical rainforests
and you see the role that edges play and
you see the role that deforestation for
uh logging for oil exploration for roads
to get to further logging and oil
exploration and just development
is playing on destroying
displaying and destroying the forests
and in changing the
makeup of the organisms in those forests
such that uh you have enough edge and
suddenly you have no interior if you
have enough patches of forest even if
they add up to quite a lot you
effectively have no intact interior
forest left and intact interior forest
is what almost all of the forest used to
be
so
patchwork habitat degradation which is
the rule of the land almost everywhere
especially in the tropics is having a
massive effect on frankly the ability of
us as humans to get back to a place
where we can live
on the planet and not be at risk of
sending ourselves over an edge and that
has
some interface potentially with
anthropogenic climate change but nothing
in that argument hinges on climate
change yeah i think this was a really
important point
those on the right have correctly
understood that there's a
garbage conversation around
climate change they have over
extrapolated to
a comfort with the level of
environmental degradation that is
absolutely out of place and um you know
i
it's very hard to describe
how um
how poorly equipped human beings are to
figure out whether or not a habitat is
intact or not yeah and when we go deep
into the amazon there are hours and
hours and hours of travel through what
looks like forest but the forest is
effectively empty this is a very real
phenomenon where the trees are excellent
and it's emptied
by lots of things it's emptied by
pesticides it's emptied by hunting it's
emptied by
certain species disappearing as a result
of economic value and oil drilling yeah
and the roads from the oil drilling
right so
so it's very hard to get a sense for how
degraded the world has become
um and so
you know you can detect that you're
being lied to you can detect that you're
being lied to about climate and it's
very much like the public health
discussion where it's like you know it's
a malinformation issue right yeah and
too often i mean just like we're seeing
with the public health
situation many of the scientists who are
supposedly doing the work actually can't
even track their own arguments like
they've just been handed talking points
and the same is true of the climate
scientists too there are some amazing
honorable scientists who are doing good
work and some of them are finding one
thing and some of them are finding other
things and
the truth is not inherently somewhere in
the middle
but given that there are a whole lot of
people who are just talking heads and
don't know how to think through it
themselves and all of them fall on one
side of the argument um tells you there
is coercion happening behind the scenes
so
we have
a
emergency of the biota
yeah we have climate change what the
source of the climate change is i mean
look i can't tell you how many times
i've been promised a nice free arctic
right it's it's it's it's fear porn
right yeah yeah i i was promised that
kilimanjaro would be free of glaciers
it's not they were treated
right but i was told they weren't going
to be there and they're still there and
i can check that right so
that ability to just simply say and i
can also
walk into a forest that i'm told is
amazon and i know enough to know it's
empty right um oh look at look at all
the intact forests are left not intact
no
it's gone and it won't come back yeah or
it won't go come back unless you reverse
the process that did this and yeah at
the time and we need to and we need to
be reversing those processes right
but anyway
the one solution to all of this
is
open discussion and that means the stuff
that says the climate isn't warming as
fast as you've been told that needs to
be aired along with the stuff that says
yes in fact it is warming and it is
warming because we're altering the
amount of co2 and the amount of methane
right and we have to have a discussion
about the fact that we don't know
if there is a threshold in the arctic
where we suddenly
lose the ability to control climate
change because suddenly those methane
clathrates are released at such a rate
that the
temperature just begins to skyrocket if
that's a danger even if it's a 1 in 100
chance
it's worth paying attention to but it is
not worth pretending
that things are clear when they are and
the solution to this the solution to the
public health issue the solution to the
habitat degradation fragmentation all of
these things the poisoning that we are
doing of ourselves by allowing novel
compounds to circulate in these
environments all of those things need to
be addressed by open scientific
discussion in which factors
on both sides are fully aired and we
figure out what we collectively think
about without imagining again and this
is a point you've made many times
that the truth is inherently somewhere
in the middle because in that landscape
where you decide in advance that the
truth is somewhere in the middle
that system will be gamed there will be
people who establish if the truth is
somewhere in the middle and
one side knows that and is willing to do
this then they take their side over here
and they go and i'm even off screen now
and they go well then the middle must be
over here and that's how a political
game is played not how a scientific game
is played because science isn't the game
science is the discovery of truth and
sometimes it gets it wrong but over time
with refinement and refinement and
refinement and attempts to falsify and
falsify and falsify
it gets to be a better and better
description of what reality is and
that's not what politics is
yep
this is not a question but a comment
which is which is nice it's fun to watch
youtube play with ideas in real time
it's like forging metal
heather usually reading pulls an idea
out of the forge you both take some wax
out of it somebody quenches usually
brett and we all get to see if anything
interesting could be made of it
q a lets watchers get in hammer blows of
their own
nice i like that i like it yeah that's
the militant moderate who who writes in
fairly commonly okay
the trolley dilemma states if we
consider that everyone has equal rights
then we would be doing something wrong
in sacrificing one even if our intention
was to save five
therefore isn't it objectively immoral
to force vaccination even if the outcome
was net positive on saved lives
um
i'm gonna say i don't think this is a
simple question but i do think you can
tell that we are not even attempting to
grapple with yeah i think that's right
let's put it this way you will discover
if you delve into the public health
discussion about um vaccines and other
treatments
that we are just simply refusing to use
the tools at our disposal that we know
work things like all-cause mortality
right
things like
absolute risk reduction right we have
the tools they're named they're well
understood and we're not using them
because somebody is playing a game in
which they want to convince us of things
that aren't true but but the tools uh
exist
in the case of
is it all right to compel vaccination
in order to save lives
this is a difficult one there is a
strong argument to be made
that it's never okay and what we have
said here is that actually in light of
the corruption of our systems they have
one and only one tool that they are
actually morally entitled to and that is
persuasion if they can persuade us to
take it fine if they can't persuade us
they don't get to mandate it because
they're frankly uh dangerously corrupt
and that is visible on many different
fronts
were they not corrupt
is there a scenario we could paint in
which
um
vaccination
was
morally
mandatable
i believe we could paint those scenarios
i believe they would be exceedingly rare
but we are not using the tools that we
would need in this case to justify any
such thing right
the fact is and basically i would say
anybody who is simply counting lives
is either
willfully ignorant of the calculus or a
liar all right because the fact is
you cannot trade a life of a child
against the life of an elderly person
it is immoral to do so right the amount
of goodness lost if you lose a child
is lark because they have so much life
ahead of them and so much room for bad
things to happen and somebody who's
already at the end of their life even if
they are lost it's not
it's not a simple calculation of a life
and the fact is these tools exist
we know this insurance companies know
the difference between an old person and
a young person why is it that that is
not why is it that this was famously
done after 9 11. right yeah
of course and the point is yeah nobody
really likes talking about the fact that
lives aren't of equal value but this is
a simple thing but the point is how much
life was left ahead of you right that is
absolutely essential and it is built in
to the nature of being a human being
right our purpose as adult human beings
is to make the world decent and
hospitable for generations to come
and we are falling down
on that responsibility
and we are harming children and it's
completely unacceptable and to do so
with the analytical tools necessary to
make these calculations simply not being
deployed and us pretending as if they
don't exist is preposterous
excellent
i'm going to let's try to get through a
few more since we have a time limit here
we got a lot of questions this week my
god so many more than usual somehow
first thing on a sunday morning pacific
time on super bowl sunday is the moment
to do it i think it is the super bowl
and also brunch that is doing this
um
i'd be interested to hear your mechanism
there off air i think um
uh it's i don't know i think it involves
um
maple
and bacon arriving on the plate
separately but becoming intermingled
just you know particular admixture
produces questions
uh no it's uh integral to brunch which
produces questions i don't need an
explanation of what brunch is oh okay
sorry
we're good i didn't know whether you
knew sure
yeah have we ever gone to brunch
we have
um
we i mean we've even had mimosas
yeah mostly with my
mom or parents on christmas morning also
your aunt
yes your aunt not your aunt that's what
it's it's one
anyway okay yes
next question
many people are afraid of guys are
mimosas inherently brunchy i guess oh
yeah okay totally see they're they're an
exception to the five o'clock rule hmm
i see
what about like eight martini lunches
from the 1960s well that's in the 60s
see they had a different different
clunk yes they
saw the world differently mostly they
saw it more blurry than we now see i
guess from the floor
many people are afraid of going to the
dentist how do you explain this
widespread fear more importantly could
you please give some tips to overcome
this or similar fears how do you both
handle it
i mean i think dentists famously cause
pain of a sort that you that is hard to
stop and that precisely especially when
you are in the chair with them
uh you you signed on for it you're like
you're inviting pain by going to the
dentist and i say that as someone who
has neither experienced pain at the
dentist nor has a fear of dentists and i
think those two things just go hand in
hand i've just been very lucky i never
had any orthodontic cavities or anything
and so i've never had pain at the
dentist
and so i just go in there and dab my
teeth cleaned and get out and i'm fine
uh that said you've had rather a totally
different experience
i know the truth which is that people's
fear of dentists is misplaced it is
orthodontist that they should fear and
um so you've been you've been put in
pain by dentists now but it's because
you're orthodontist as it is
fault right yes i had a bad run in with
an orthodontist who moved my teeth too
fast and wrecked their roots and
i
i even now have trouble letting him off
the hook though he is
quite certainly dead by this point
because he was pretty old at the point
that he did this to me but um
anyway yes orthodontist i have learned
in
my own personal experience i have
learned from mike mew and from the
reading that i have done in light of all
things mike mew
are a very dangerous lot proceeding from
a
absolutely appalling misunderstanding of
why malocclusion happens
and uh really they i think probably what
they've done they probably have
um better pr people can i remind you
that the question is can you please give
some tips for how to overcome this or
similar fears i'm showing them you're
not helping
no the okay i'll i'll put it into a
simple method the way to get over your
fear of dentists is to focus on how much
more frightening orthodontists are
okay
i'm afraid this person may ask for their
money back
next question
is
is dating a vaccinated person dangerous
in regards to the spike protein shedding
by the way i love your show hope you
never stop
well look i've heard they're shedding
stuff yeah um no i've seen i've seen no
evidence either way i find it almost
impossible to imagine that a person
could shed enough spike protein in a way
that other people would contact it that
it's worth thinking about that said
that's my gut too on this let's put it
this way i wasn't
i didn't see how people with a good diet
were going to be vitamin d deficient
i now see it so is there something here
failure as as as dawkins has famously
said right failure to imagine is not an
argument right so my gut on this is like
i don't think so but i've seen no
evidence either way yep
um
sorry i'm not
my wife and i had covered last month and
i had it once in april 2020.
the home country of my wife requires
facts for entry so it's facts or don't
see your family
where to get information on vax after
covid
and its risks
i've seen
nothing
i've seen the recommendation that you
get super immunity if you have both
which is
ridiculous in which case you know if
that were true it's the only disease
known in which that's the case i think
they pre-bunked that one they pre-punked
it um but
i haven't seen any research and you know
the there's so much research now i don't
claim to be up to date but i haven't i
have specifically not seen anything on
um
on the effects of vaccination after
having coveted uh with the
caveat that there might be a um
what is it an antibody dependent
enhancement problem
um
maybe
but that's just that's like that's um
that's speculation it's not data
one thing is
we and others have successfully
embarrassed these people on the subject
of natural immunity
and
it is now acknowledged that natural
immunity is superior to vaccine immunity
anywhere that reasonable people gather
does that mean that these systems will
be updated
so that your natural immunity can
substitute i don't know because
obviously there's something about this
it's a campaign to vaccinate everybody
irrespective of whether it makes any
freaking sense to vaccinate them right
so that driving force is not necessarily
blunted by the update on natural
immunity but the update on natural
immunity has occurred and people are now
backtracking where they made insane
claims is it true
that um
vaccine immunity plus natural immunity
is super immunity
it is almost certainly a very tiny tiny
tiny bit true but in no way that should
matter to anyone right now it is also
possible
that to the extent that natural immunity
is protective that giving you a vaccine
that then detains a bunch of the immune
system mesmerizing it with antigens that
has been warned about by your infection
could depress your immunity and this is
the next thing we should be
investigating is that to the extent that
they're saying well of course you should
get the vaccine because everybody should
get a vaccine and really you want more
vaccine rather than less vaccine and
that whole thing right
the point is look
even if it is technically true that
there is a tiny bit of extra immunity
that you will get if you have had an
infection and then you get a vaccination
is there a period in which the
vaccination compromises your natural
immunity by
by
gumming up the the immune cells that
were alerted to the infection itself
probably and i mean
god damn it but like
vaccination is supposed to be a way to
get exposed to the thing without having
to take the risk of being exposed to the
thing
like this is
a side version that's supposed to be
safer than and equal to
and yeah these vaccines aren't exactly
vaccines and so that may be part of the
argument that's hiding but they can't
really say that can they but if it's an
actual vaccine then having the
immunity garnered from actually being
exposed to the thing and having your
body mount its defense
is simply better
than having the sidelined version that
is safer yeah the sideline version which
is if we're talking about like an
attenuated virus vaccine like a
traditional
vaccine that would be safer
but a way to a way to get your immune
response to be mounted in the same way
but without the risk in this case
the
vaccine in question
is so narrowly targeted that it couldn't
possibly be the equal of natural
immunity right it just can't be not even
in principle right so
um and also you know
they're like a thousand things in which
we're trying to raise the attention that
the public health authority is actually
just shuffling papers and pretending to
be interested in your health right why
is it not interested in t cells
this is where the better immunity comes
from right it's obsessed with b cells
why because you know what they are
you've heard of them right and so the
point is to mesmerize you
they're going to talk about
antibody response right oh greater
antibody response you know and the point
is it's an accounting game it's very
hard to detect how much t cell immunity
you have but that's the durable immunity
that is likely to be more protective and
an actual infection will give it to you
and their vaccines will not
and so
i guess i you know as always the
question is something like how many
times would these people have to be
wrong before
uh we're entitled to stop listening to
them okay we got 34 questions and we
have like a maximum of eight minutes
here before we have to get going
no we can't but let's just try to answer
a few quickly okay
um
sam refuses to take statins for high
cholesterol because of minor side
effects presumably this is sam harris
he's talking about so why shame those
that don't want the vaccine if coveted
policy is based on death count shouldn't
we force sam to take statins
well there's obviously
an infectious disease argument that
doesn't apply to the statins but to the
extent that he could end up in the
hospital i mean look i'm not a believer
in this anyway but yes the argument
has uh has
some of the same characteristic
um yeah uh i would urge brett to abandon
this american habit of calling the left
liberals i am a socialist as bernie
sanders liberal as thomas jefferson and
conservatives roger scrutin
usa is constitutionally liberal
it's interesting constitutionally
liberal i think that's right
this is the british version of
of liberal yeah
yep
uh can you steelman the argument that
the truckers are bullying ottawa
residents are they doing actual harm
should there be a time limit on the
occupation there love you both thanks
i'm gonna have a very hard time standing
this because i've been watching a lot of
the livestream and i've been hearing
from a lot of people uh
i've been hearing directly from a
handful of people whom i now know up
there and seeing a lot of live streams
and therefore hearing from a ton of
strangers who you know have a microphone
stuck in their face and asked
what it is and um
i mean i think you really have to define
bullying in a way that most of us would
not recognize as bullying to get that um
actual harm no and in fact if um
i was thinking you know if
but for the
authoritarian
uh desires of the government to make
this as hard on the truckers as possible
this could be uh reinvigorating the
economy of uh of the ottawa core by you
know lots of people coming in you know
lots of people there all the time and
then the weekends even more people
pouring in who presumably need to eat
and stay places and such um and just one
more thing should there be a time limit
on the occupation there well that's of
course not how protest works you know
they went to get a response and the
response has not happened and so the
response has no chance of happening if
they're like and we're out in a week
like well okay we'll just wait out for
another week
well
um
i don't think i can do bullying i can do
harm yes there's harm
um
you know on the other hand i think it's
absurd
to try to do this a la carte
right these this is civil disobedience
it is doing harm it is snarling uh
ottawa but it is snarling ottawa in
order to
um
to get redress of grievance against an
authority that has so much power that
there's no other mechanism and so um the
question yes are ottawa residents going
to be harmed more than victoria
residents by an occupation of ottawa
they sure are
um will the american and canadian
economy by heart be harmed by the
snarling of the ambassador bridge sure
will but the point is
when did we forget
that there is a right to do harm when a
cause is sufficiently important and
there's no other mechanism
right i mean you know
we go to war we go to war we send people
into battle
if a cause is sufficiently important
and
you know is this harmful yes but
what is really harmful is turnkey
totalitarianism that is not being
answered that's right so um to the
truckers
the harm is warranted hold the line yeah
that's right
uh i this is just a comment i'm an
editor for exec level dod which i think
in this case means department of defense
mal information was added to required
language in january now all refs to
wrong think must include miss dis and
mel info
interesting
must include miss dis and mal info
oh man it's a complete solution
set yeah okay
um
big pharma's eua
emergency
authorization yes
uh big farmers emergency use
authorization immunity goes away if five
alternatives exist yep as we talked
about
10 months ago here 11. oh it's february
now yeah anyway which would explain the
push to quash them and universal
insistence on jabs is the only
acceptable solution
recently
uh it says jfk junior but he must be an
rfk junior
spoke of laws that provide immunity from
liability if a drug is declared approved
for children
which would explain the push to job
children
thoughts
i hadn't heard him say that um i had not
and it's not in his book as far as i
remember um that's
i mean i think
i'm sure he makes errors um but
his his stuff is so well researched and
he's got the the references so if he's
making that claim i suspect without
having fact checked it myself that um
that he's right
just because he's right doesn't mean
it's not mal information
um yeah i know i know um
i would just add that um
there's so many shenanigans across so
many domains right because yeah we also
have the situation
where the eua
covered
one set of vaccines and then something
that is supposed to be the same vaccine
yeah um was authorized no was
that's the other a you've got emergency
use authorization and approved yeah then
the vaccine was approved but the point
is if you get
the
eua version literally the vial that was
covered by the eua
they still have immunity from liability
and that's at least until recently if
not still the only version being
distributed in the u.s right which is
obviously
their plan
to give the impression that you're
dealing with something that has been
approved while retaining the
level of legal protection from when it
was simply authorized in an emergency
yeah
i read that attenuated polio vaccines
can de-attenuate back to virulent form
seems unlikely with random mutation how
does this happen what is its importance
well
it depends
i think i mean it can't happen but super
super rarely
i don't know i don't want to pretend to
know but i will say i can steal man a
mechanism right okay so
many uh
mutations
that change
uh phenotype things that change your
actual form in the world are what's
called loss of function mutations
sometimes it can take just one change of
a nucleotide or one deletion to take a
gene effectively offline right and so if
you have a defective um
brown eyed gene you might have blue eyes
in spite of having the gene for brown
eyes because the pigment is disabled
right i don't know if that's a actual
example but that's how it works the
point is depending upon how they
attenuated
the vaccine
there's a question about a single
change that caused the virus not to be
harmful could be easily reversed
and could bring it back online now of
course that's something that to the
extent that it happened commonly would
probably mean that a vaccine was not
viable
i will say
again this brings us back to this
distinction that i've been trying to
draw between an actual attenuated virus
vaccine and
omicron which has been argued by some to
possibly be a contagious vaccine
a contagious vaccine could
evolve a change which would then be
passed on
a um
attenuated virus vaccine even if it
changed unless it changes to become
contagious those changes will die with
the individual
and so this is an important distinction
that we we have to track
um
god okay there's so many good questions
here and we need to we need to free zach
here so i've got um
just
five of them of the so many that we're
gonna miss here two of which are
comments
uh we'll start with the comments and
then quickly address the last three uh
and then we'll be gone next week but
we'll be back in two weeks 13 days
thank you for supporting and sharing the
freedom convoy it means a lot
absolutely yeah
this has been a long time in coming and
the fact that the freedom convoy has
captured people's imaginations that they
have
maintained discipline shown great
courage uh it makes us
so happy that they exist and
um you know
hold the line and frankly it is down to
the rest of us to protect them from
these governments that have carved out
uh extraordinary rights to do things to
people who stand in their way that's
right
and then another comment
christian conservative loving your
podcast finally a good from the pandemic
question
thank you
okay three more questions um oh this one
i'm gonna punt uh and you know how
different would life on an earth-like
planet be
so so so different
uh i've in fact written a science
fiction novel about this which at some
point i will return to and uh and
hopefully release into the world but i'm
just gonna say so so so different for
now so different
could vitamin d deficiency be a factor
in causing depression much love
yes i think we actually know this i
think we i think this is one of the
known effects i hope i'm not wrong about
that there are definitely some
uh mental health effects known uh to be
associated with vitamin t vitamin d
deficiency i would say
one thing is going to be unambiguous
again if we're talking about very little
effects
certainly if you are more prone to
infectious disease as vitamin d
deficiency will make you then that's one
contributing factor to being depressed
right that's just getting sick so it's
certainly indirect that's for certain
yeah
and finally
if our ancestors evolved to use as few
unnecessary calories as possible when
and why did we start dancing
thank you both for all you do
those are not unnecessary calories those
are the most vital expenditures of
calories and um
if you don't know that you're doing it
wrong
can you try a slightly less
tongue-in-cheek response
um yeah i would say
dancing is one of many activities
that
clearly
passes the adaptive test
it is clearly where we should presume
that it is more than paying its way does
not mean every act of dancing
is productive but especially if you
look back at uh more traditional forms
of dancing the relationship that this
has
in uh courtship and
uh in important rituals
is
profound and it's not too hard to see
where the payoff would come from
all of that
and i think the question
is wonderfully instructive in revealing
how when focused on a single parameter
we can forget that it's not the only
thing in play
that
sure calories being limiting
organisms will tend to try to conserve
calories and act in ways that bring them
more calories more
efficiently
but calories being limiting is not the
only thing affecting affecting life
and
and
quality of life and propagating into the
future
so uh it is exactly by focusing on
single metrics is that sort of
reductionist approach
that can reveal good faith questions
like this
but can also get us into the kinds of
mess that we are in right now with
public health where we are told one
thing and one thing only must be our
focus for [ __ ] is it two years now i
mean my god
covet is not the only thing going on
guys and there are a lot of questions
that we all should be having about
whether or not it should have ever been
the only thing on all of our minds but
at best there might be a justification
for some weeks or maybe a couple of
months maybe
but the idea that there is one and only
one consideration therefore
if you see something
that runs counter to that
it must be miss or dis or mal
information
tells you most likely that the person
who's claiming that's miss or disembowel
information either has a single focused
interest that may not be your interest
in keeping that the only narrative or
they're just deeply confused and not
worthy of the position of authority that
they've given that they've been given
two years to flatten morale
that happened pretty quickly yeah and
here we go like
two years to flatten morale but two
years in and we've got the freedom
convoy
and morale there
is not flat like they they are doing
extraordinarily valuable
work yes uh and they are having a good
and honorable time doing it and more
power to them absolutely again hold the
line
all right i think we're done i think
we're there all right uh be good to the
ones you love eat good food
and get outside be well everyone
[Music]
okay
well
[Music]
you